en une décennie avec luc ferrandez le
plateau mont royal a beaucoup changé
il a beaucoup fait pour nous donc on est
reconnaissant il faut se rappeler qu'il
y a dix ans il y avait sur le plateau
essentiellement deux pistes cyclables
pour rouler nord sud il fallait
absolument emprunter la rue brébeuf et
le parc lafontaine et pour rouler est
ouest il y avait essentiellement la rue
rachel aujourd'hui il y à beaucoup plus
de voies réservées aux bicyclettes
toutes les pistes cyclables le maire a
clairement été pro vélo sans oublier les
nouveaux espaces pour les piétons et les
mesures qui ont ralenti la circulation
chaque été on voyait plus d'armes qui
plus de d'amélioration sur le plateau
les parquant aussi beaucoup changé par
exemple ici au parc laurier à van basten
stationnement aujourd'hui c'est un
espace beaucoup plus vert avec entre
autres du mobilier urbain pour se
reposer et plates et plein d'atouts ce
qui a fait le pain la rue était barrée
il avance des autobus qui paraissait
c'est infernal vraiment là
- il vient manger pas de tout le seul
accroc aux différents bref luc ferrandez
part avec encore beaucoup d'admirateurs
mais pour certains son bilan est loin
d'être un sans faute
il ya moins de voitures mais par contre
beaucoup plus de vélo puis les vélos
sont par définition plus indisciplinés
ils font un petit peu plus ce qu'ils
veulent c'est plus compliqué luc
ferrandez c'est aussi la multiplication
des sens uniques l'hiver sa politique de
déneigement en a fait rager plusieurs
sans oublier la multiplication des
parcomètres et des vignettes qui ont
retiré aux non résidents des centaines
de places de stationnement on parle
entre eux tiers et la moitié de toutes
les espaces de stationnement qui sont
disparus pratiquement du jour au
lendemain par des vignettes de 9h à 23h
aucune compensation il a été donné
plusieurs centaines de commerçants dans
les dernières années
qui ont laissé leurs chemises après 25
30 ans 40 ans d'affaires ce
professionnel en affaires sur le plateau
a été souvent exaspéré par le maire
d'arrondissement ya un prix à payer
quand on est commerçant
quand on est en affaires de dénoncer des
politiques municipales
quand une bonne proportion de peut-être
vos clients votent pour ces gens là les
gens l'ont aimé beaucoup ou carrément
pas du tout le ferrandez ne laisse
personne indifférent ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal